mr. Dante tell us why you're here at the
3d film festival I was all rather sudden
actually because I iya wasn't aware that
there was a 3d film festival until last
week when they called and said they were
running a hole and would I please come
down and talk about it so I want you ok
and tell us about the whole the whole is
a 3d movie I made almost two years ago
and it's a sort of a retro 80s family
horror picture that I more or less
talked to producers into making in 3d
and it's real 3d not fake 3d not a fake
movie that was shot normally and then
sent into a computer and then came out
of three day this was a real 3d movie
and unfortunately we didn't go quite
anticipate the onslaught of fake 3d
movies that we're going to be coming out
in which we're obviously in competition
but we did win an award in the Venice
Film Festival for the best 3d movie and
over some things are moving to know us
and so I think that we did make an
attempt to to use it use the medium you
know artistically and not just throw
things of people of your bill and
switching gears a little when you were
starting out in your career what were
some of the hurdles that you faced
professionally and how did you overcome
this is a long shot it could be the
Reader's Digest version it could be
through studies version this is such a
different world then than it is now that
kids are always asking me how did you
start in the business and I mean I can
give them the answers but they are
completely irrelevant because the
business has completely changed we
bought I worked for me a certain kind of
movie for a certain kind of audience
than no longer exists for distribution
system that
exist and I was lucky enough to get into
the ground floor right around the time
that B movies were being made with more
money and had become a movies and you
know when the advent of jaws and Star
Wars which were essentially the kind of
movies that had been not taken very
seriously in previous years all of a
sudden were gigantic heads and lots of
money was lavished on sequels and
imitations all of a sudden B movies
became a pictures and I was the
beneficiary of that and how was it
working with Roger Corman I know he's
very efficient on the set well Roger you
know had a distribution operation that
was very very frugal and lean and one of
the tenants of it was to hire people who
he could get to work from less money
than anyone else because they didn't
know anything and we approached our jobs
at roger corman's as if this was the
only movie we were ever going to get to
make and we were lucky to get to make
this one and so all the tricks and terms
that we learned in order to stretch a
dollar and try to get 40 setups a day
where they're all valuable lessons and
if you look at the roster of people who
went through the Roger Corman school as
we call it it's tremendous amount of
people who went on to have been careers
and lastly what hurdles are you facing
now as a director well it's just it's
just such a different world movies are
now very expensive or very cheap the
middle ground movies more or less
disappeared and there's a lot of people
who want a job and not that many jobs to
have so the keeping your head above
water and just staying in the business
becomes
major concern it's a it's a very
difficult environment right now for
filmmakers because of the as many les
films made and there's a lot of
competition and there's a lot of
pressure to make and homogenized a big
big studio movie into something get
everyone will love and very solvent does
that work plus the time you just end up
as something that's imagine eyes and
bland the AG kind of movies the guy grew
up with in 70s are very difficult to get
somebody to finance these days
Oh